what-t-t well well well, it's time for another video slippy. what do you have to say about
What do you have to say about
your appearance on this channel so far from a scale to 1 to
your appearance on this channel so far, from a scale to 1 to 10
10. be as specific as possible about every single detail. go.
Be as specific as possible about every single detail, go.
You changed, man. You fuckin changed, man.
you changed man. you fucking changed man. you used to be better than that slippy.
You used to be better than that, Slippy. Don't - don't look at me with those sexy eyes,
dont - dont look at me with those sexy eyes, its not gonna work again. :(
As you all know, I love - I love the media, you know, news media I think is a wonderful thing.
as you all know, i love - i love the media. you know news media i think is a wonderful thing.
Mainstream news media. It's the greatest thing
mainstrain news media is the greatest thing... e - e - ever
E-e-ever
It's done - It's done me many great things, you know, I owe my entire career.
its done - its done me many great things you know, i owe my entire career - thats right slippy - i owe
That's right Slippy.
I owe my entire career thanks to media.
my entire career thanks to medium (media?)
Slippy: But no one cares about the media.
but no one cares about the media
Felix: Oh, really? Oh, no one cares about the media Slippy, oh okay
oh really no one cares about the media slippy
oh okay what if i told you, that your entire species, is a hate symbol. (rekt)
What if I told you that your entire species is a hate symbol?
DRAMATIC.MUSIC.OVER.PEPE
[Dramatic music] *lol
thats right, oh now you care? now you care?
i see how it is slippy. i see how it is.
As you may know, the media has been trying to find problems with YouTube now,
as you may not know, uh - the media has been trying to find problems with youtube now.
you know they went after me, the guy on top. you know - PHASE 2: go after the site itself.
you know they went after me, the guy on top, you know.
Phase two:
Go after the site itself.
uh - seems to be the case. you know the whole ad boycot thing.
you know they went on the whole 'restricted mode thing'. it was a big - it was a big thing wasnt it slippy.
now uh, theres a new video coming out, and its from uh
Now there's a new video coming out and it's from news channel 10.
NEWS CHANNEL 10
NEWWS CHANNNEL 10 my favourite - this is where i go, for all my latest info.
NEWS CHANNEL TEN!
My favorite - this is where I go for all my latest info.
well they made a report on youtube. its amazing, i love it so much.
Well, they made a report on YouTube.
It's amazing
I love it so much. Keep doing this shit, media, because it's - you're giving me content, essentially.
keep doing this shit media because its - hil - your giving me content essentially.
And Slippy, if you weren't outraged before you will - you will be now.
aand slippy, if you werent outraged before, you will - you will be now.
ok, here we go
idiot:"seemingly innocent videos are making their way - "
eheh. hehehe. its already making me laugh because
i can just tell by looking at that these two, that they have no idea wtf youtube is
like this guy.. does not go to youtube. ok
like this guy does not go to YouTube okay?
VIDEO: - way into the homes of families all across the country.
idiot:" - way into the homes of families all across the country, videos that are disguised, as something else.
-Conspiracy music plays- FELIX: They're disguised...
theyre disguised, just like pewdiepie was disguised.. as a nazi.
have you opened your eyes yet? and so, the rest of youtube must be in secret disguise as well.
Have you opened your eyes yet?
And so, the rest of YouTube must be in secret disguise as well.
idiot2:"news channel 10's merry coleman joins us now, with more on how easily accessible they are to children"
VIDEO: News Channel 10's Mary Coleman joins us now with more on how easily
accessible they are to children and what you can do to protect them.
idiot2:"and what you can do, to protect them"
FELIX: Can someone please protect the children?!
CAN SOMONE PLEASE protect the children. fuck man, i see this from time and time again.
Fuck man, I see this from time and time again:
"well we must protect the children. think about the children."
'Well we must protect the children. Think about the children. Only children watch Pewdiepie, so we got to be careful.'
"only children watch pewdiepie so we gotta be careful."
its like BISH have you seen my demographics. ok.
It's like BISH
Have you seen my demographics? Okay?
13 - 17, the smallest one. 18 - 24, 25 - 34.
13 to 17?The smallest one.
65+??? what the fff.. wait i have actually people older than 40 watching me. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
65 and plus? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)﻿ What the-?
Wait-- I have actually people older than 40 watching me?
what - shoutout to you guys wtf are you doing with your life.
idiot3:"thousands of youtube videos are re-"
is she wearing fucking tassels as earrings.. im sorry i cant take you seriously  any more.
FELIX: Is she wearing fucking tassles as earrings?
I'm sorry I can't take you seriously anymore.
idiot3:"containing disturbing and even violent content."
VIDEO: Containing disturbing and even violent content, and your children may be looking at those.
idiot3:"and your children will (100% defo) be looking at those"
But just as easy as it is to search for these videos, it's as easy to block them. Felix: Problem solved!
idiot3:"but just as easy as it is to search for these videos, its as easy to block them."
PROBLEM SOLVED. hehehe. great
VIDEO: On the surface, these videos seem innocent and fun, but if you m--
idiot3:"on the surface these videos seem innocent and fun" ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)﻿
OHSHIT, courtesy youtube.
FELIX: Oh shit! "Courtesy: YouTube."
-Laughing-
ehHAHAHAHa. eheh. thank you youtube for letting us - uh - use this clip
VIDEO: The worst part? They are being disguised to lure in kids.
idiot3:"the worst part, theyre being disguised to lure in kids. and with youtube being so popular, that isnt hard."
And with YouTube being so popular, that isn't hard.
VIDEO: And the parents are actually com-
idiot4:"and the parents are actually complaining - "
WHAT WAS THAT. what was that? WTF is that shot. what is hap -
Felix: What was that? What was that? What the fuck is that shot? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)﻿ What is that?
THUMBNAIL!
Thumbnail! XD
VIDEO: - completely oblivious to it most of the time because they're either
idiot4:"actually completely oblivious to it most of the time, because theyre either"
gasp
idiot4:"far away from the child or the child has headphones on"
idiot4:"and theyre kinda doing their own thing, and they dont realise that the child is actually watching something"
idiot4:"really inappropriate so we cant use youtube as a baby sitter" (wtf?!)
yes you can. theres an app called youtube kids. it has a very strict - ewheyer - guidlines on whats allowed on
youtube kids. just - uh - download youtube kids app, you dont need restriction mode. just download the
youtube kids app and stfu honestly. it was made for parents, who have free entertainment, to watch there.
idiot3:"its unclear why those posting these videos are doing it"
idiot3:"but there are a few things you can do, to avoid your children being exposed to them"
idiot4:"make sure you have the parental exclusions - uh - set up in youtube. and you can do that directly"
idiot4:"on their website. and what that does is it excludes - umm - more adult"
andrew brandt - all star computer service
* intense googling intensifies*
what the fuck is that. this just went to a computer service shop. why.
idiot5:"you need to make sure your kids are watching disney vid -"
whats with the god awful earrings im sorry. ayaya - it bothers me more than this whole report at this point.
idiot3:"youtube also have a specifc kids app, another option for safety
(dont forget condoms tho)"
OH YOU NEW ABOUT IT
Reporting in Amarillo,  Mary Coleman, news channel 10. Felix: It's weird because these
channels exist as some sort of Disney content. It's basically like the Chinese...
knockoff of Disney that's just made it huge on YouTube. Is Frozen
[cackling]
where did they go?? XD
yashhh!!
The frozen Elsa video *lol XD
WTF?!
did someone actually screen it and was like..
THAT ONE IS FINE ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)﻿
This fucking video has Elsa spanking in it! "Spank Elsa Butt"!
There must have been some fucking mis-flag,
you know? They must have thought that this is like a Frozen Elsa video like all those fucking Webs & Tiaras and shit.
"Frozen," "Frozen Games," "Family-Friendly"!!
[cackling]
He likes it, boy! Just comparing the revenue between my "Can We Save Youtube" video and my Frozen Elsa video...
Like it by just comparing the revenue between my can we save Youtube video and my frozen, Elsa video
Which pretty much have the same amount of views
which pretty much have the same amount of views...
five times more five times more on the forbidden, Elsa video the Spank, Elsa butt video
Did you just assume my gender?? Family-Friendly Felix [singing]...
[Family-Friendly Felix jingle plays]
My favorite family friendly game. What should I slap her with? A fucking... blap!!
Anchor: Parents are being warned about a pastime traditionally seen as innocent. News channel 10's
Mary Coleman joins us now with more on - Felix: Oh, there's more!
Anchor: - allowing children to watch YouTube should be aware of.
I heard that he's a Nazi. I don't want my kids watching no Nazi. I don't even want kids to watch me, all right?
I think I used to but I don't cater to kids like it's not what I do. All right guys,
hope you enjoyed that video. If you enjoyed it - always a like is appreciated. Whatever you want to do, check out another video and uh...
Just thanks for watching! I'll see you tomorrow with another one and as always...I guess I don't really always do it,
fuck